Hey guys, now most of you know the
amazing story of David and Goliath.
I mean, you hear it everywhere,
because it inspires people to
also overcome the challenges in their lives.
And I mean, who cannot be inspired by David,
an underdog who everybody thought
would not be able to defeat Goliath.
A shepherd's boy, he came and did it
when everyone in Israel was afraid.
I mean, they had fierce warriors -
strong guys - but they were afraid.
And then here comes David.
Fearless.
Think about this.
Even his own father did
not include David at first.
When he let all his other
sons stand in front of Samuel.
When Samuel would choose the new king
from Jesse's sons. Listen to this.
[1 Samuel 16:10-12]
So here, God chose David to become
the king of Israel, the future king.
But Saul was still king.
And in this time the army
of the Philistines, they came to have war
with Israel, and with them, came a champion.
Their champion, the giant Goliath.
And this is what happened.
[1 Samuel 17:3-4]
Now how tall is that?
That's around 9 feet and 10 inches.
That's around 3 meters.
That's huge.
Imagine you stand in front of a mountain.
Man, giant, 3 meters tall.
He wasn't just tall but he was he was very strong.
I'll get to that in a minute.
I want to mention something interesting here.
He was probably from the tribe
from the people of the Anakim.
If you watch my video on the Nephilim, the
mighty man of all the giants, you would know this.
But if you haven't, go check it out.
It's a very interesting series that I'm covering.
We also know that Goliath had brothers - other
giants - and here's the thing.
Today you have a lot of people
who who grow tall and there are medical problems
you know and usually they're not always strong.
But these giants were strong.
Listen to this:
[1 Samuel 17:5-7]
His bronze armor alone was 125
pounds... 56 kilograms ... that's heavy.
I mean, you can try to put it on and
just walk a little bit but put that
on ... walk for miles towards an enemy...
and then have the energy to still taunt
them and ready for a battle.
You won't be able to do that.
[1 Samuel 17:8-11]
So this probably wasn't just a normal giant even.
This guy was fierce, almost looked like he had
blood in his eyes, ready just to to kill
and devour these little men, like straw,
because the whole of Israel,
they were afraid of this giant.
I mean, they must have had
powerful champions as well.
Strong men but even they were afraid
at Goliath because Verse 24 says:
[1 Samuel 17:24]
Now you know what happened next ... David
without fear came against Goliath and you
know how that ended for him. But there's
a lot of things that people don't know
about the story or that they miss
and I want to share that with you.
But before I explain that to you, you
need to understand something else first.
And that is that this was not just a battle
between a man and a giant - between Israel
and the Philistines - this was a battle between
good and evil, the battle that all men and women
face in their lives.
Listen to this:
[1 Samuel 17:42-43]
So Goliath cursed him with his gods,
and this is important because we
know that these gods were demons.
Remember Deuteronomy 32:17 says ...
Paul also says in 1 Corinthians 10:19-20:
Go watch the series that I started on the
truths that all men need to know about life.
In that video series I explain my experience with
demons growing up and after that, also the history
of how men started to worship demons thinking
they are gods and how religion started before
the flood and after the flood.
Now, let's move forward.
[1 Samuel 17:44-45]
You see, David did not fight through
the flesh with his own power.
He fought with God's power that
was in him, through the Spirit.
You see, he did not have self-confidence.
He had God confidence.
He said in Verse 46:
You see, David had no fear.
He knew God was with him,
that God's spirit is on him, guiding his own will.
His own emotions, his own intellect, his soul.
You know, that's the difference.
We talked about this on my channel a lot,
between self-confidence and God- confidence.
Now David knew that God's spirit is on him giving
him the strength and that is why he had no fear.
How do we know this?
How do we know this
that David acted through the spirit?
It happened back when Samuel anointed
David to be king.
Listen to this:
[1 Samuel 16:13]
Now, this is amazing, because not only did
David act through the power of the Holy Spirit,
not only that, but he ran towards Goliath.
Towards the thing God wanted him to face.
This is amazing.
Normal men, even
the most powerful men in the army of Israel,
they looked at Goliath and they were afraid.
David had no fear because of God's Spirit in him.
Not only that, but he he ran towards him to fight.
How many times have you buckled because of fear?
The challenges, the obstacles, the problems in
your own life? How many times have you buckled
out of fear because you acted in your flesh and
not through the power of the Spirit?
God's spirit that is in you.
Verse 48 says:
Most people miss this.
Without fear, because he
was in the Spirit, acting in the
Spirit, he ran towards his enemy.
To face him.
Quickly.
Fearless.
Man, how amazing is our God.
Verse 49:
Wow, this is amazing.
You know, you might not
face a giant Philistine, but you will
face many challenges in your life.
Many obstacles.
And you cannot run from it.
Neither can you fear it.
You cannot face it through your own power,
through the flesh. You need to face it with
the power of the Holy Spirit who is in you.
If you are a real child of God.
So many people run away from their problems,
their challenges, their giants, because of fear
and this is important to understand because if you
do that, those problems will just stay there.
Those challenges will stay there.
Not only that, they might grow, and there
will be more problems that's added to it.
So later on in life you'll just be carrying
a heavy heavy load so big that you'll
buckle under the pressure.
You need to handle your
giants the moment they surface.
David also said in Psalm 56:3:
The moment you fear, you need to understand that
that is the moment that you're not trusting God.
That's when you are starting to act in the flesh
through your own power and not in the Spirit.
And you have no excuses because today
since 2,000 years ago after Jesus Christ,
all reborn believers, when we accept Jesus
Christ as our Lord and Savior, He gives us
His Spirit so you have the Spirit of God in you to
help you to overcome any challenge in your life.
[Acts 2:38]
And listen to this:
And you will - not maybe - not probably -
you will receive the gift of the Holy Spirit.
You need to understand this.
When you are declared righteous,
when you come to repentance, when you truly accept
Jesus Christ as Lord and Savior, when He makes you
a new creation, He gives you His Spirit.
You are sealed by the Spirit.
[Ephesians 1:13]
So how do you do this?
How do you overcome challenges in your life?
You need to be weak.
Weak in yourself to
such a degree where you deny yourself, your own
selfish desires, your own self-determining will.
It needs to be under the power of God.
He needs to sit on your throne, not you.
It is only when you come to the end of
yourself - your own power - oh me me
me - it is only when you come to the end of that
life where you surrender to the power of God,
where He can start to work through you.
Let me tell you when you do that, when you let
the Holy Spirit work through you and guide your
soul out there in the world, everything you do,
everything you say, everything you do.
Then, nothing will be impossible for you
to accomplish God's plan and purpose for
your life, because He will give you what
you need to accomplish it.
And He will give you the
power through the Holy Spirit that is in you.
And the Spirit of God who is in you is not afraid.
[2 Timothy 1:7]
Satan, on the other hand, he uses
a spirit of fear and uncertainty.
In my new book called Bold Pursuit,
a 90-day devotional for men seeking the
heart of God, I explained it this way:
[Psalm 27:1]
Wow, this is amazing.
You know, David was just a man.
Just like you and me.
But God called him a man after my own heart.
Why?
Because he lived within God's will.
He did what God wanted him to do.
He lived according to the Spirit.
So let me ask you, why if you are a child
of the living God, with His Spirit in you,
who wants to help you, who wants to guide you, who
wants to give you strength to overcome challenges,
who wants to lead you in everything you do
- why do you want to carry on and fight the
challenges in your own power?
You, a small human being.
So little and tiny.
Temporary.
One day you're here the next you will be gone.
Dead.
We are so small but the God of the universe
wants to help you His Spirit is in you,
and it is the same spirit that
rose Jesus from the grave.
[Romans 8:11]
Now, if you want to learn more how to grow deeper
and deeper in Christ, to become stronger ... a
mature Christian .... to learn what it
means to abide in Him, to fully surrender.
Oh, there is so much that we
as His children can learn.
You know, the Bible says that we have already
received all spiritual blessings - do you even
know what they are?
It is time to grow.
We cannot stay babies in Christ.
Infants in Christ.
We need to grow so that we can become stronger.
If you want to grow and please get my new book,
I'll add the information for you in
the video description, and you can also
watch these videos here.
And I'll see you there.
And always remember - that God
loves you - and I love you, too.
Life is short, so please do not waste yours.
Bye guys.